>> Dave: BEVAN MILLS, LINESMAN.
THROUGH.
STEVENB STAMKOS KNOWS WHAT TO
DO.
IT WILL PUSHOFF.
YOU KNOW aul: CIRELLI GOES TO T
NET SO HARD.
HE JAMS THE PUCK IN.
IT IS A CROSS, CREASE
>> Referee: AFTER VIDEO
REVIEW, THERER
TWO SUZUKI, COUSIN BACK.
NICE PASSES.
THERE.
BYRON COMING.
SEE HOW THEY ALL ARE ON
DIFFERENT LAYE
SCORES!
THE KID DOES NOT MISS.GING GUYS
WERE LATE COMING BACK OUT THE
ICE.
THEY DO THE RIGHT THING.
THEY DON'T OVER PASS TOO MANY
TION THE SEASON.
SCHUENEMAN WITH THE DRIVE, THEY
SCORE!
THE MONTREAL CANADIENS ARE
WHICH IS WHAT A GOALTENDER HAS
TO DO. AND SCORES!
JOSH ANDERSON, RIGHT UP THE
MIDDLE!
AS MONTREALNOT.
IT IS A FLAT OUT BREDOUARD-
BELLEMARE.
SHOOTS, REBOUND,ONE
TIMER.A QUICK SHOT.
THEY SCORE!
IT IS PERRYFERENT LAYERS.
THAT IS THE KEY.
FOOT COMES OVER INTO THE MIDD I
THROWS IT BACK UP TOP. AND